natalie so good to see you last time i
saw you we were on an
island catching up and you're getting
ready for winners at war
and you came in second so we're finally
catching up i mean how was that
experience for you the place you came in
and how are you doing um yeah it's been
a while since
the whole finale obviously the the ride
was wild
yeah it was like the the best but then
like the weirdest
ending because i knew i didn't win but i
had this amazing journey
i knew i was going to get targeted early
i didn't think it was going to be
the first vote the saving grace is that
i had extinction and
my saving grace on this season is that i
could redeem
myself and come back into the house by
just going out
up and taking somebody else out so i
love the challenge because no matter
what
you can't get sent home unless you lose
an elimination so that was awesome
i love that and you know the fact is
you've been on survivor the amazing race
and here you are with the challenge i
mean
you live for this stuff don't you like
have this adrenaline rush kind of thing
it's part of your vibe yeah i think you
know i'm just really good at this if i
would have gone on the challenge unless
i knew i had a
really good shot of winning i had this
uh
feeling of like um disappointment of not
winning winners at war and so i was like
okay this is redemption like it's all
physical nobody has to i don't have to
please anybody to win
i just have to get to the end and then
destroy everybody i was like this is my
cup of tea so
i think i'm obviously it's not like i'm
searching for this but i
i'm just so well suited for these shows
that it's impossible for me not to say
yes and it's also impossible for fans
not to kind of gravitate to towards me
and be like i need to see natalie on the
on the challenge
yeah and you started off with a bang
getting rid of a two-time champion
you got your gold skull to run tj's
final and then you
team up with wes i mean these are all
great moves why did you want to team up
with wes um wes
had something i could didn't have which
is he had the
the social proudness and he also had
just a lot of connections in the game i
didn't know
some of those connections are just
really bad connections but
uh my my choice was between darrell and
weston i just felt so honored that i had
these two
multi-champion vets coming towards me
and being basically fighting for me as a
partner
uh the reason i chose west is that
darrell is just too much like me we're
just really
low-key in the house and i needed
somebody with a little bit more pull
and a little bit more protection like um
and was
just really he's like a student of the
game like he's so
into it and um and he knew the what he
was getting into
choosing me as a partner i knew he knew
i had a target on my back and he was
willing to work with me
besides being physically strong and
being able to compete
was had this social game that i couldn't
com
like i could i didn't have because i
don't have the relationships he had and
he's just like obsessed with you know
winning and
uh he has like a really unapologetic
attitude about it so
uh yeah i just gravitated to him he's
also his wife
i was a huge fan of mine and uh he
spoke to me about how much his wife
loved me and so that was really
it wasn't gameplay because i've talked
to his wife since coming home and she
said
you have a chance to pick natalie you
better pick natalie or
when you come home you're going to be in
a lot of trouble
do you have any regrets i mean you guys
were the first ones eliminated last
week's main challenge and
you were the target for the during the
deliberation is there
a slight regret no for me it was a dream
scenario i got to go get my ghost skull
and i came back into the house uh with
wes as a partner and both of us
that's nadia brother had uh nadia
[Laughter]
i'm here with him yeah
my dream scenario like i went in i
proved to them why they were scared of
me
and i came back with my ghost call and
wes and i kind of solidified this
amazing bond that
i used him in a way that like i felt
like i'd known him forever the way he
coached me
and then this is trend
oh my goodness is that you talking in
the background hi sweetie
she came to the beach on uh for winners
at war um
little itty bitty baby yeah she's so
cold is she now
she just turned to oh she's adorable
yeah you really had his back too wes's
back were you shocked that bessie voted
for kyle and nani
um i didn't know that they found out
that you could see who was voting for
who
um i was shocked i thought it was west
and i going back in
um i just you know i just didn't want to
be paired up with joseph so i was like
wes
if you go in you better win because i
don't want to be paired up with this
lunatic um
but uh i was i had no idea what was
gonna happen i thought they were gonna
throw us back in
uh and i was just happy that kyle was
able to beat uh
um what can we expect for the next
episode
so the next episode basically wes and i
have established ourselves as
enemy number one in the house at this
point
like after we got targeted wes and i we
both have embraced this target
and it's our job to kind of figure out
when wes can get his ghost call
and him kind of telling me what to do at
this point i'm chilling like i've got my
ghost call and i
take west's lead moving forward uh
because it's his life now on the line he
has to get his ghost call and he has to
stay safe so
uh i've done everything i need to do if
i get to a final
i know i can win so nobody's going to
come for my skull i can guarantee that
none of the chicks want to take my ghost
call from me so uh
yeah moving forward i'm just ready to
you know roll with wes
and obviously you can tell that i'm not
i don't want to trade up west i'm
willing to go to the end with him so
i take i'm willing to take west's lead
for the rest of the season and
uh you know win this money yeah you know
what i love the fact that you talked
about
representation and being the south asian
woman during the launch special and
how important it is and this has to be
one of the most diverse cast of the
challenge for you what does that
represent do you think
there's change happening and i mean you
must be so stoked
yeah i mean uh i said this you know i
was the first uh
uh you know brown person on survivor and
i i ended up winning my first season so
i was like this is
new casting us on these shows and then
uh you know species have pakistani which
is awesome i didn't know that till i met
him
and so that was awesome and obviously
repres i feel like i'm the same person i
am
on this show as i am on survivor uh but
it's just awesome to represent i've got
so many dms from
young southeast asian girls saying that
they watch the show
and they've never seen anybody who looks
like them and represents
their demographic so shut up
so um it's just awesome to represent and
just be who i
am and be authentic and this is my
brother-in-law um oh
they hate me they hate me right now oh
come on
tell them they're talking to us come on
you never even watch my season and he's
a lolo jones fan because he was a track
runner
oh come on you should be a fan of yours
you're talking about the fact that you
were the first winner at south asian of
survivor and cbs is making a lot of
changes they're talking about diversity
jeff
probs is stepping up you know it's the
sole survivors organization they're all
stepping up
uh the fact that they are acknowledging
it that must mean a lot to you knowing
that you are part of a show that is
actually recognizing change
yeah i mean it's awesome i even joked
around with jay in the house and he's
half spanish
uh he was in a room with three black
guys and i looked at j and i was like
did you notice that you're the white guy
and it's three
and you have three black roommates and
we would just joke around even my room
was uh it was me
theresa nissa and tori and i just
that was i'm i was used to being my
first season of survival i was the only
like minority and then uh you know very
few
from so the change that has happened
from my first season of survivor to this
cast like it's just astounding i would
just literally be in the house and look
around and be like
this as well this is an mtv show which
used to be
a majority white challenge like the
challenges the real world
majority white and i would just be so
proud like you know that
people can acknowledge that they need
change and then not only acknowledge but
then follow up with the actual steps it
requires to cast
people that look like you know your
everyday neighborhood and like cast
we were so diverse it's crazy like uh
everybody looks so different there was
so much like
biracial um like different countries
were represented it was awesome
is there the challenge in the future for
you uh
so i heard that they're casting um i
mean i feel like
i honestly went into the season saying
i'm gonna go in
and win so this is what i'm gonna say if
i win this season
and if i end up winning i think i might
just be like you know what that's good
for me
i've got my uh my winner's title yeah
it is uh one and zero uh but if i don't
win
it's just so hard for me to say no to
shows like this even if i do win but
um you know like i said i'm just too
good at these shows to say no because
the money is like basically guaranteed
in my pocket if i don't mess up so
um
you